let's rock it Suresh cut Friday it's
fresh cut Friday Friday
you got yourself you went high and tight
kept it long on the top no I wanted it
longer alright guy came over and I said
I said Papa Papa listen
don't touch the top I want it very long
on the top short on the side mask up did
he have clubs did he mask up
he had gloves on all right he wasn't
masked up now all right so you got a
case the old kovat hair yeah maybe
whenever though but I told him don't
touch the top and that was in front of
Marika's cut it in my kitchen there's no
mirrors in the kitchen Oh turn it up and
and I go yet you know cuz I could tell
it's gonna be an issue I can tell
because he goes it's not even cutting
here so long and the client wants one
thing I know what's best for them oh
that's it yeah he was like some guys
they want this but I Tom short here's
the way to go to it yeah but sometimes a
client might want something then if you
give something else they'd be pretty
upset he goes now I usually pretty happy
I thought this isn't good
but there's nothing I can do kids got my
ear and I hear it going that here tiger
go oh you're here is short Papa I'm like
yeah I'm thinking sides and then gets a
man I'm like that's not what I asked for
an ulcer looks fine I'm not mad at it
but not what I asked for dude we would
meet the day that I'm time like the
weekend I met Luke Rockhold but bright
before he's gonna fight Chris Weidman
and I was looking at him we were talking
and at one point I looked at her I know
how tall he goes six three and he's
smiling at me and his hair was short and
I had long shitty air I knew I wanted it
and I went time for me to get that I can
look like Luke and I went to Supercuts
cuz everything yep and a woman who was
very varied for whatever reason very
overweight but but it's very interesting
very overweight but also took a lot of
time in her appearance so she had
piercings in that's super hot were a
nutshell there you go and so very sweet
woman and she she said I said I wanted
to be short and I said but you know I
have a longer face so don't cut it too
short on the sides well she she went oh
that means I'll shave the size anyway
and she just went to town there's now I
was like ooh you're cutting a little too
much I didn't want to say it I want to
say that she'll stop now didn't stop no
one says anything just go oh hell yeah
yeah let's just dope and now I'm like
what the [ __ ] you doing dude you just
you just take it you take it yes and I
didn't look like Luke this is what's
crazy now this one
I didn't look like Luke and when I went
back and Tariq and and I think Yosef saw
my hair they went oh you look nice
haribol nightmare I go and then Targa's
you were trying to look like Luke and I
go yes I was and it didn't work out for
me man now yeah my buddy who it was his
barber he goes so come to your house
he's great he works his bah-bah-bah I'm
like right that means he's probably good
if he's cutting those famous people here
he's probably good he goes but make sure
you're very specific give them examples
so I'm like well I just typed it I
googled long hair on top shaved on the
sides men and like Macklemore popped up
Jeezy popped up so I'm [ __ ] showing
them these I'm like it's I need it like
this like longer than shaven yes oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't yell at Alec now
know if it's gonna work oh my god dude
I'm that's what I want pop I don't know
you dude just cut the [ __ ] here I
wanna climb in here but he's an artist
and he knows what looks good on
someone's head I suppose you know I'm
Gilardi Ames from the chicas oh you are
there dig in the hair alright got like
there right away all right
it's nice look you didn't like the you
didn't like I liked his rougher biker
look with the long oh you know are you
talking about like poor like biker gang
look yeah see here's another problem
mountain biker now part of the club
you're still not in we're working on it
we're thinking about it we're working on
it I've had some people hooked me oh
they said I we can hook you up with a
bike yeah sure yeah still get me the
club just cuz you get a bike well
there's the kid remember still bother me
for you now alright so I was riding my
bike yesterday Pablo's going very fast
and had to fix the chain came I've had
to fix it I had the it was 97 degrees
out there and Mahone and my hair's there
I was like dude this hair slow me down
some professional melt like you're
professional professional ok ok no I got
to keep going
yeah ok so I figured hey guys here's
slowing down my lap time eyes on the
mountain I'm gonna get rid of you want
to feel the wind on your scalp a little
bit little bit well I know holding back
dude I took my shirt off because that my
shirt was dragging really on hill took
the shirt off right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[ __ ]